bonsoir odile du veau merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors votre
biotech un an thèse est notée rat est
présenté comme très bien placés pour
développer un traitement prometteur pour
qu'on comprenne de quoi s'agit-il
alors dans les traitements contre le
gobie de 19,6 à tout un arsenal
thérapeutique ce qui manque aujourd'hui
ce sont des anticorps susceptibles
d'être actif contre tous les variants
donc nous avons mis au point depuis
maintenant plus d'un an un anticorps
collectionna lé dirigés contre le virus
est par définition un anticorps
polyclonale ça a réagi contre les
variances que nous avons pu vérifier
cette semaine c'est pour ça que nous
avons pu aussi avancer dans nos
discussions avec les gouvernements sur
une option de commandes qu'ils
pourraient faire auprès de nous afin de
garantir que le traitement sera
disponible pour la population française
dans les meilleurs délais alors odile
dumeaux c'est très important ce que vous
nous dites vous dit
les variants ça veut dire tous les
variants et dans quelles conditions se
sont passées ces essais cliniques sur
combien de personnes notamment
alors nous sommes dans la phase des
essais cliniques des démonstratif mais
nous sommes très confiants parce que
l'efficacité des anticorps contre les
virus sont déjà est déjà bien démontré
dans bien des cas alors il faut savoir
qu'il y à 16000 mutation du virus qui
sont aujourd'hui répertoriés
donc vous imaginez qu'en combinant tout
ça ça fait beaucoup de variants ce que
nous avons fait c'est que nous avons
pris un certain nombre de variantes les
plus fréquemment démontrer et surtout
ceux qui sont connus pour augmenter la
létalité et les risques liés au virus et
nous avons pu tester l'efficacité du
gsem 19 qui est le nom de notre
médicament contre ces variants nous
avons eu la bonne surprise de constater
que l'efficacité n'était absolument pas
entamée par ces variants pour répondre à
votre question sur les essais cliniques
nous avons un essai clinique en france
qui est déployée aujourd'hui
dans bientôt trente six hôpitaux et dont
les résultats définitifs pour l'instant
les résultats préliminaires sont
attendus dans les prochaines semaines et
en parallèle de ça nous avons un essai
européen nommé euros grave qui
confirmera sur des patients légèrement
différent c'est à dire des patients qui
pouvaient qui pourront être
éventuellement à domicile l'efficacité
des anticorps de notre anticorps pour
les soigner effectivement dans une
pandémie comme celle ci la stratégie
vaccinale est indispensable et c'est une
très bonne nouvelle qu'elle se déploie
rapidement maintenant dans la plupart
des pays
mais au-delà de ça les anticorps et
toutes les stratégies thérapeutiques
sont absolument indispensables parce que
c'est intéressant d'apprendre les thèmes
uns après les autres si vous le voulez
bien vous dites tous les variants ça on
l'a compris et ça semble être plutôt une
bonne nouvelle à qui ce traitement
serait était destiné toutes catégories
d'âge alors le traitement est destiné à
toutes les catégories d'âge mais de fait
on sait que les personnes les plus
susceptibles de s'aggraver sont les
personnes en général de plus de 55 ans
on va dire donc le traitement est
destiné aux gens qui vous savez après
cette phase initiale qui est souvent
bénigne dieu merci donc à un certain
nombre de gens s'aggrave et commence à
avoir des troubles respiratoires parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se défendre
efficacement contre le virus
c'est à ce moment là qu'interviennent
les anticorps pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur aujourd'hui les 1500
personnes qui sont hospitalisées tous
les jours dans les hôpitaux en france
seraient susceptibles de bénéficier du
traitement par l'exode 19 vous parliez
justement du vaccin comment envisager
votre traitement il est complémentaire
on s'est en attendant le vaccin alors
vous savez dans la plupart des maladies
infectieuses même quand on a un vaccin
il faut toujours des traitements pour
des raisons diverses soit des gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés les gens qui
n'auraient pas répondu avec suffisamment
de force aux vaccins des gens qui
n'auraient pas fait le rappel
les rappels sont nécessaires tout cela
fait que les besoins sont toujours
existant en matière de traitement alors
maintenant bien évidemment dans une
population vaccinée on espère que les
besoins vont diminuer je vous ai parlé
de 1500 patients par jour
nous nous estimons que nous pourrions
avoir besoin de 300 à 500 traitements
par jour dans les prochains mois et les
prochaines années ce qui reste tout de
même un besoin très conséquent et qui
mérite qu'on s'en occupe up on s'occupe
des manades vous savez quand on est des
humains
alors oui bien sûr vous disiez ça fait
un an que vous êtes en recherche sur ce
médicament
j'ai le vous aviez fait connaître votre
projet en mars dernier c'est à dire
juste avant le premier confinement ont
pouvoirs publics avec a priori comme
seule réponse des encouragements
alors nous sommes une biotech donc les
biotechs ce sont des petites entreprises
qui sont susceptibles d' innover avec
beaucoup d'agilité et avec des coûts
beaucoup moins importants que
quelquefois des grosses d'entreprises
malgré tout lé financement ne sont pas
forcément très évident pour nous et nous
avons dû effectivement trouver notre
chemin dans les financements l'état
français a réagi à peu près de moi mais
nous avons d'emblée été soutenu par la
région pays de la loire et par nantes
métropole
donc ça ça a été un premier pas ensuite
l'état français leur a emboîté le pas en
finançant en particulier l'essai
clinique actuelle en france qui
s'appelle polycor alors on est au stade
où on a bien avancé
maintenant il faut avancer sur la
production et être prêts être rendez
vous pour les français qui auront besoin
d'ailleurs pas que les français aient
forcément mais qui auront besoin de
traitements pour lesquels aujourd'hui
nous préparons une production à
l'échelle industrielle
mais pour cela il nous faut de l'argent
évidemment vous l'avez alors il faut de
l'argent à nous gbagbo vous l'avez cet
argent l'état a fini par vous
subventionnez parce qu'on a compris que
c'étaient les régions qui avaient
répondu présentes mais pas
nécessairement l'état central entre
guillemets alors il ya une tribune
politique qui a été mise en place il ya
quelques mois
le ministère de l'industrie aujourd'hui
qui vise à relocaliser la production de
médicaments et donc l'état a pu ainsi
dégager des fonds pour co financer des
investissements industriels
nous allons être bénéficiaires de ces
investissements même si les choses sont
pas encore complètement calé ce qui nous
permettra de préparer l'outil industriel
pour produire le graphe 19
maintenant une fois qu'on a une usine il
faut la faire tourner et l'étape d'après
c'est effectivement de demander à l'état
s'il est prêt à s'engager pour ce qu'on
appelle des précommandes chose qui se
fait aujourd'hui de façon systématique
dans beaucoup de domaines au prix des
vaccins comme vous l'avez noté et qui
est indispensable parce que il faut bien
comprendre que la compétition
internationale aujourd'hui et portent
principalement sur l'approvisionnement
dansez dansez vaccins et dans ces
traitements et la raison pour laquelle
vous avez proposé au gouvernement de
dialoguer sur cette option de
précommande donc ce dialogue a démarré
et nous espérons bientôt conclure un
accord positif pour les deux parties
c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite en tout cas
si les essais cliniques sont favorables
vous avez sentiment que vous pourriez
vous retrouver dans cette situation
similaire à celle de val neva on en a
beaucoup parlé à une eau bio tech
française justement qui a fini par
vendre son vaccin expérimental au
royaume-uni faute de financement et de
soutien français
alors c'est effectivement donc moi je
connais bien valeeva puisque c'est une
entreprise qui elle aussi est né dans
l'écosystème dantec est très favorable
c'est effectivement une question
j'allais dire presque morale qui se pose
pour une biotech comme comme nous
pourquoi parce que nous avons le choix
entre une anticipation de la production
de façon à pouvoir mettre à disposition
les traitements le plus rapidement
possible pour les malades et une attente
de résultat que nous pensons favorable
avec beaucoup de confiance
et si nous attendons les résultats nous
allons perdre six mois en gros ce que
nous avons estimé c'est que le risque
serait que nous croyons pas au rendez
vous pour ce qui risque d'arriver
à dire de nouveau une expansion de la
pandémie au moment des mois + frais
cette pas tenir à l'automne voient
parfaitement avant l'été donc et ne pas
espérer pour les français justement
profiter de ce traitement rapidement on
imagine évidemment les conséquences de
cette lenteur est également merci en
tout cas odile dumeaux d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france
présidente de la bibliothèque nantaise
est notée à merci beaucoup à vous